I have this uh this video I want to pull
up for you that's going viral Ian miles
Chong uh has this tweet life is hard and
it's getting harder for the middle class
I'll just play a little bit of this clip
for you guys
seriously my bills alone are three
thousand dollars a month I'm a single
mom who receives like 300 a
month in child support for two kids
I can't do this anymore
I work every single day I get maybe a
day off sometimes if I'm lucky I'll get
two days off
I'm sick of it I'm so sick of this
and I forgot to pay my
daughter's braces and now I have to
bring her in for them to remove them
because I can't afford to pay it all off
at once
I am so sick of this country I'm so sick
of how expensive everything is
something needs to happen and that's
something is Donald Trump no I'm half
kidding uh but maybe if you uh uh to
this to this woman and not personally
but in general
the economy was really really great in
2019. it was nice I went uh I love
telling the story went to a furniture
store we were starting the podcast this
is like January this is this is January
of 2020. and uh starting team test arrow
and I said uh I'd like to buy some
furniture we need a table that we can
sit at and so we bought a table and the
woman who was doing the sales was really
excited as she wrote up the five
thousand dollar ticket for all the crazy
stuff we were buying to build a studio
and uh she was laughing she was like she
was like thank you so much she's like
wow she's like I gotta be honest it's a
really great day for me you walked in
and just bought it on the spot and I was
like well we know we needed it you guys
had it we had checked it out before and
she was like man it's just been going
really good for me and I was like what
happened she goes this has been the best
year of my life she's like I've never
made more money we had a contractor
doing work for the for the studio and he
said I've never made more money in my
life it's been absolutely fantastic then
covet hits
Trump loses now you have Biden and all
the ramifications that came with kovid
which was both Republicans and Democrats
and now you have these people under Joe
Biden sang I hate this effing country
I'm sick of how expensive everything is
it's like okay
let me show you another story
let me see if we have it here from uh no
it's not there here we go from the
post-millennial Washington power company
raises rates to cover increased expense
due to climate legislation AG's office
instructs them not to tell consumers
raising for higher prices Key
form came bone form the vague Rama Swami
goes on stage and says that the the the
climate change agenda the anti-carbon
agenda is the wet blanket on the economy
it's right there in your face so if
you're wondering why it is that you are
struggling blame the Democrats and the
far leftists and the people who are
trying to shut down energy but hey don't
let me just give a free pass to
Republicans I'm not a big fan of them
either but if you're coming and
advocating for a carbon neutral energy
policy and then telling us we can't have
nuclear energy I say F off you're a liar
because they are a liar because nuclear
energy is the cleanest most efficient
power it's also the most carbon neutral
one so like from their own talking point
of the most important thing more so than
anything else is that the energy that
we're getting is as carbon neutral as
possible nuclear energy per kilowatt
hour is exponentially more carbon
neutral uh than than the so-called
Renewables are we also have an issue too
where nuclear energy is something that
we can generate here in the United
States whereas solar on a generator
do that we're like solar and wind we
have to go buy all that stuff from other
countries import it over here using
fossil fuels of course for our boats and
whatnot yeah it's also the safest form
of energy production nuclear is yeah so
yeah the Boomers for that because this
is 100 the Boomers yeah because like
there were there were nuclear weapons
they freaked out because they had to
hide under their desks in the 1950s as
school children and then they took over
the world and decided to delete
everything that was worthwhile it's your
fault Dad it's the whale's fault it's
the wheels if we were only still using
weight yeah I was gonna say I want to
hear this it's the whale's fault and I
can explain okay sweet delicious whale
you know if only I'm kidding uh I've
actually had whale before it's
disgusting and I don't recommend it
seems greasy uh I was really looking
forward to that theater no no it is I'll
explain it okay uh so Greenpeace right
they were concerned about nuclear tests
that were being done uh in the ocean the
initial purpose of Greenpeace is my
understanding was to stop these nuclear
tests so they would get their little
boat and they would go and sit in these
areas where they want to do nuclear
tests and then they were like we can't
do it because they're there and part of
the reason was that it was devastating
to whale populations it saved the whales
one of the co-founders of Greenpeace
broke off and formed sea Shepherds to
protect whales so this initial activism
to stop nuclear weapons from Greenpeace
transformed into a desperate well now
that we stop something that's bad how
can we squeeze the tea and milk all
these other morons for their donations
and Greenpeace went from let's stop
nuclear bombs into how can we lie to
people to keep maintaining our facade of
environmentalism they now just say
whatever stupid garbled nonsense they
have to to trick morons into giving them
money one of those things is that
nuclear power is bad and they Revel in
it because they make lots of money from
it it's a cash game and it's beautiful
profit and going back to what Libby said
it all started with their opposition to
nuclear weapons testing so this would be
like opposing solar panels because of
melanoma or something like that it has
nothing to do with it it's literally it
is what and in fact uh the reason that
we tend to use the less efficient hard
water reactors is because the U.S
government and other governments
prioritized the production of nuclear
weapons over actual energy production
whereas newer forms of nuclear energy
production like uh thorium salt reactors
and things like that are far more
efficient uh the half-life than the uh
the half-life of the of the waste only
lasts like I think like 100 years
instead of tens of thousands of years
I've been reading about that in every
way it's better it's meltdown proof I'm
not going to try again I'm not a
scientist I'm just a Jew but I I I in
every way it's even safer than nuclear
which is already exponentially safer and
better than everything now we've got the
Advent of fusion which uh I believe
they've already reached an ignition big
stories now they've actually they're
trying to figure out how to actually
capture the energy from the ignition
process miniature Sons I guess uh that's
going to kick off an energy expansion by
which human rights has never experienced
and we are going to we Elon Musk we need
you
rapid energy expansion if I don't know
the actual numbers for what Fusion the
exponential increase in energy output
that we'll get from Fusion relative to
fossil fuels but the uh I believe
nuclear is the most efficient I believe
correctly the highest energy output that
we have yeah uh it's remarkable it's
carbon neutral and it's got a massive
energy output and they won't do it so uh
I watched this really amazing little
mini documentary on energy it starts
with human energy we eat food convert
that food into kinetic energy through
our muscles the sugars and we build
things we then figured out hey this big
you know creature over here can pull it
for me and say straps it to a cow made
the cow pole it's animal energy then we
started burning wood then coal we get
petroleum all of these rapid expansions
of energy extraction rapidly increase
human population technological
development Etc
once Fusion kicks off if we get to that
point where we've got Fusion reactors
everywhere we need spaceships and we
need them fast well and that's the whole
point right the whole point of humanity
to a large degree anyway is to create
more stuff to go faster to go further
right so you could look I mean people do
they look at the history of humanity as
the history of energy consumption and
energy creation and we do that and so
like we hit fossil fuels which was great
which elevated so many millions of
people out of poverty globally and now
we're asking the entirety of humanity to
take a step backwards by using less good
energy resources instead of exploring
and developing better ones nuclear is
the way to go forward or this you know
this other Fusion thing right it's the
way to go forward that's how we get to
other planets and that is of course the
goal is to like keep going whether or
not we go to other planets can be your
opinion whatever we can simplify this
for the average person explorers right
but I just want to say this for the
average person says bro I don't care
about Mars I don't care about Venus I
don't care about Neptune or Alpha
Centauri or whatever whatever I just
want to know why I can't buy bread you
can't buy bread because they are putting
a wet blanket on the economy they could
build nuclear they ain't gonna do it
they want to shut down your fossil fuels
without giving you an alternative
because the real answer the real reason
they're doing is probably communism and
so they want to restrict what you can do
control what you can do and you suffer
because of it keep voting for them look
I don't blame this lady who's talking
about her kids and the hardship she's
dealing with because everyone's dealing
with that I don't blame the working
class for being exploited but to a
certain degree I beg of these people to
pay attention it's why it's so important
when people are like I don't pay
attention to politics I'm like dude I
have little respect for that because you
can't complain about why the prices are
so high and then say but I don't do
anything about it or even know why or no
why your complaints there they mean
nothing to me yeah you come to me and be
like well my house is burning down I
have no idea what's happening I just
like lighting matches in my living room
I'm flicking him onto the floor and I'm
like okay well maybe that's what caused
your problem maybe you did a thing and
you're not paying attention to it and
you burned your house down
oh go ahead I'm sorry no that's it that
you keep voting they keep voting for
this I was surprised in the video that
you can repossess someone's braces yeah
that is sort of fascinating to me well I
think the issue is they have to get
taken off and so she has to choose to
pay to have them removed or go into like
default go into debt from the
maintenance of them I did always wonder
that though like for any of these
procedures or like Invisalign or any of
this if you run installment plans what
happens if you don't pay it they repo
they repay they repo your braces or your
retainer I I don't think that's what it
is I think the doctor is more than happy
to leave the braces on your mouth
indefinitely because screw you can't pay
oh and she's saying I can't afford this
so we have to stop so we have to stop
and get them taken off oh okay right
yeah it's like a long you know I I
battled this in 2020 because I was
traveling the country campaigning for
vice president and I would talk to
people who go yeah you know things are
bad but if they could just you know get
us reliable checks and I was trying to
explain to them like okay what's
happening right now is they've
essentially shut down production for the
most part and they're going to print out
ridiculous amounts of the currency that
you use every day to buy things and
they're going to hand it to you but in
doing so they're also going to hand a
bunch off to the multi-trillion dollar
companies at the same time and they're
going to get the Lion's Share of it but
in doing so they're going to greatly
expand the amount of of currency without
adding value they're actually taking
away way value by making you stay home
so you have more money chasing fewer
goods and services and in very short
order once things begin to turn back to
normal you're going to see shortages
you're going to see supply chain issues
and yeah you're going to see rapid price
inflation because price inflation is
just an extension of monetary inflation
and that's what we've seen and you know
you had a handful of people in DC like
Thomas Massey and and Justin Amash and a
handful of others who were speaking out
against this everyone else either
because they wanted it or because they
were afraid to go against the corporate
media narrative about it they went along
with it and we're now suffering the
consequences of it and to be fair uh I
was uh more in line with the uh with
Trump spend the money figure it out and
I think hindsight being 2020 we now
realized the mistake that was but I
think for the most part too many of us
trusted the machine when it said we are
dealing with the deadly pandemic we all
we saw these videos coming out of China
and I think good people tried to be good
people and said look you know like these
people collapsing it's terrifying now we
look back and we're like okay it was bad
but like man did they over hype this and
drive us into the ground over nonsense
and the real reason was probably
political control thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time